there's a new superhero movie doing
baffo box office
it's the super surrogates yes the
democrats five super surrogates have
teamed up to stop loki's hoard of gop
senatorial candidates from invading
you've got bill joe
michelle hillary and barack
and look what they can do with their
combined superpowers
wow
it is time to unleash the potential of
kentuckians
give you a chance to have somebody who
cares about you who will live and
breathe and work for you these mid-term
races will be even harder and even
closer than those presidential elections
but they're just as important do you
hear me they're just as important i
think you should vote for the future a
future of shared opportunities and
shared responsibilities hope is the
belief that there are better days
that we can build up a middle class and
give back something to our communities
and hand down something better for our
kids
hope is what built america
not cynicism this is not your father's
republican party man
this is a different breed of cat
this is a different outfit no i'm not
making a moral judgment
i'm not saying they're good bad or
different they're just different man not
indifferent different
they're just different
joe bond would say literally with all
due respect to ted cruz chris christie
those are five super surrogates bill
clinton's clearly the class of the field
in either party of the other four though
now who do you think is the strongest
surrogate in the closing days here for
the day well look i mean just on the
pure like what do i like to watch most
man i'll tell you it's got to be joe
biden man because he's the best man but
the person who i think is the most
effective of the others is michelle
obama because you think about what
democrats have to do they have to get
out african-americans and other uh
minority voters they have to turn they
get a lot of women out she has the
capacity she doesn't have she's still
super popular she doesn't have even
though she has the last name obama she
doesn't have her husband's baggage
politically and when she gets out there
in terms of rallying the people that
need to rally she does better than me i
could make the case for any of the other
four i think they're all pretty good and
the point is there are five of them and
they're all out there we don't want to
disrespect dr joe biden but she's not
quite the same class but those five are
extraordinary surrogates and and to the
extent get out the vote and message
matters here at the end the fact that
president obama is not going everywhere
doesn't matter in be as much as it would
because you got the like how you
weaseled out answering the question
there uh i'm for uh
president obama